well is joe biden up to the task here
with reaction
former secretary of state mike pompeo um
i look at this did john kerry in the
trump years mr secretary
did he conduct covert
foreign policy negotiations the very
thing that we were lectured
general flynn did with his soon-to-be
counterpart
uh when he was going to be national
security adviser
with the iranians and do you believe
that
muhammad zarif is correct in what he's
saying is that a possibility
and if it is what would that mean to you
sean thanks for having me on it it looks
like from this reporting that it's
confirmed what we
can already believe which was that while
i was briefing president trump
carrie was briefing zarif on
intelligence that related to
israeli operations i hope that's not
true
john kerry needs to come forward
secretary kerry needs to speak to the
american people and explain to them
why he was meeting with zarif we know he
did that he's admitted as much
what he was talking about we believe
that he was absolutely telling the
iranians hang on
this pressure campaign the power that's
being exerted by america against you
it'll be over we'll win this election
it'll just be four years you can hang in
there don't don't for a minute negotiate
with the trump team
and so secretary kerry's got an awful
lot of explaining to do
there's no reason to think that these
remarks that zarif made according to new
york times they were made in private he
didn't think they were going to come out
there's no reason to think
that he wasn't telling you he was truly
surprised that he did not know
about these israeli operations until
secretary kerry told him about them
do you have faith trust confidence
that joe biden will be able to handle
the
iranians now he wants to get back in the
iranian deal
well now we have the u.s navy being
tested
right now at this hour my question to
you is
what is the proper response
sean i'll tell you what president trump
and our team did we had the same issue
they were driving irgc the
expeditionary forces the iranians they
were driving rgc coast guard cutters
close to our ships president trump made
clear to our naval officers and our
sailors you have every right to respond
you have every right to blow them out of
the water
and when we did that and we communicated
that to the iranians
that activity ceased we need to make
sure that our sailors have the ability
to defend themselves
you know sean people may have forgotten
but when secretary kerry was in office
last time when he was a secretary of
state the iranians not only
put cutters around our ships but they uh
seized
our sailors you remember those pictures
sean they were sitting on the pier they
were kneeling down
they were being held by the iranians
that only an apology from secretary
kerry
was able to get them back that wouldn't
have happened on our watch
it didn't happen on our watch last
question if the iranians
if we go back into this deal you saw the
last deal
hundreds of you know all the millions of
dollars billion dollars
given to the iranian muellers we had no
anywhere any place anytime inspections
what are we going to get in exchange for
this deal and do you see anything
and isn't there a real reason that the
israelis the u.s the egyptians
jordanians
the saudis uh have now united against
iranian hegemony
what part of this does joe biden john
kerry kamala harris not yet
you know we isolated the iranian sean
like they've never been isolated before
you name those arab states add the
emiratis as well
they'll understand that this deal puts
them at risk and our israeli friends the
jewish homeland is under threat
if we give the iranians this money again
it reduces american security as well i
do not for the life of me understand
why they would give the iranians
something in exchange for almost nothing
just for this thing that appears to be
an article of faith for them
to go back into this deal to say they
did at this this this crown jewel of the
kerry secretary of state time
it would be a big mistake and it puts
americans at risk
peace through strength the only thing
that works and uh the only thing the
iranians understand mr secretary thank
you for being with us hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else